[Music]
hey everyone happy new year and welcome
to another installment of harry potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be discussing the complete history of
the sacred 28
let's start with the most obvious
question
what is the sacred 28 well as you may
already know it's actually more of a
question of who
rather than what alright so who exactly
are they and how did they come to be
well the sacred 28 is a pureblood
directory of the wizarding world's
supposed most pure-blooded magical
families which is to say the witches and
wizards whose ancestors had not muddied
their bloodlines with muggle integration
this extremely prejudiced list was
released in the first half of the 20th
century
sometime in the early 30s
although the author of the publication
remained anonymous it was widely rumored
to have been penned by catankaras not
with the knot family of course making
the list
however whoever the author may have been
there is little doubt that the idea
behind this despicable directory began
with the intolerant ideologies of
salazar slytherin one of the four
founders of hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
you see salazar was extremely open about
his anti-muggle sentiments and not only
did the sacred 28 encourage the
discrimination of muggles it also
outlined the same wizarding families who
salazar himself had believed to be of
pure magical blood the assertion that
some wizarding families were more pure
than others was met with mixed review by
the wizarding community
some openly rejected their inclusion in
the directory as they rightly knew that
their relatives had married muggles in
the past and they did not feel that this
fact made them less than other magical
families however sadly many more
wizarding families were upset at not
being on the list
so who were these families that came to
be known as the sacred 28 let me take
you through each one from a to zed
abbott listed first in the directory was
the abbott clan
however it's believed that this
particular family only remained a pure
blooded one until around the 1930s
soon after members of the family married
either muggles muggle-born witches and
wizards or half-bloods we know this for
certain as hannah abbott a hufflepuff
student who attended hogwarts at the
same time as harry potter was a half
blood hannah's mother was tragically
killed by death eaters which further
suggests that they did not align
themselves with those who believed in
blood purity
later hannah fought in the battle of
hogwarts and after school she married
neville longbottom
other habits of note include the
hogwarts portrait of a gifford abbott
and theophilus abbott an american wizard
and possible relation to the british
clan avery not much is known about this
particular family within the harry
potter universe what we do know is that
the avery bloodline is a pure one and in
more recent history many members of the
family became death eaters
black
this is of course the last name of
harry's godfather and james potter's
best friend sirius black
the black family had a prestigious yet
dark reputation with members of the
family including loyal voldemort
followers like bellatrix lestrange
and narcissa malfoy
every member of the black family with
the exception of sirius was sorted into
slytherin while at hogwarts and the
majority of the family adamantly
believed in keeping bloodlines pure
often referred to as the house of black
this dynasty was one of the biggest and
longest-standing pure-blooded wizarding
families britain had ever seen
in fact its origins went all the way
back to the middle ages as depicted in
the intricate mural of the blacks family
tree which hung in the ancestral home of
number 12 grimmeld place in london
bullstrode this wizarding family was
mostly pureblood however similar to the
abbott family line some members must
have married muggle half blood or
muggle-born spouses after the creation
of the sacred twenty-eight we know this
to be true as millicent bull strode
another contemporary of harry's was a
half-blood witch
you may remember millicent as the
slytherin student who hermione tried to
impersonate using polyjuice potion in
the chamber of secrets
unfortunately for hermione it was
millicent cat hair that she used in the
potion
transforming her partially into a cat
but my digress
burke
if this name sounds familiar to you
that's likely due to karakticus burke
being one of the co-founders of borgin
and burke's the shop in nocturne alley
that specialized in dealing with dark
magic items and rare mystical artifacts
borgenenberg's was of course the shop
that housed one of the two vanishing
cabinets that draco malfoy used as a
passageway into hogwarts in the half
blood prince
garacticus burke also held possession of
salazar slytherin's locket which he
procured from voldemort's mother when
she was desperate for money throughout
the series there was also mention of
elizabeth burke a witch featured in one
of hogwarts portraits that hung in the
southern dungeons elizabeth's likeness
was heard encouraging southern students
to be nasty to mudbloods
caro the carrots were a pureblood family
with a dark history indeed a member of
the carrow family was a known acolyte of
gelat grindelwald in 1920s and who could
forget the vicious caro siblings alecto
and amicus
these two taught at hogwarts during
voldemort's uprising in the 1990s as the
professor of muggle studies and
professor of defense against the dark
arts respectively they were quite
proudly death eaters and would use the
cruciatus curse to torture students in
the name of discipline and education
while snape served as headmaster after
dumbledore's death
crouch the crouch family was one of the
oldest pureblood wizarding families in
britain with supposed relations to the
families of black yaxley longbottom and
weasley bartimius crouch was a
high-ranking official at the ministry of
magic head of the department of magical
law enforcement to be exact making it
rather awkward when it was discovered
that his son marty crutch jr was a death
eater unfortunately due to some rather
poor judgment on bartemius's behalf
barty crouch jr was able to escape from
azkaban an event which led to a series
of rather terrible events including the
murder of bartimius bharti's
impersonation of maddai moody as a
hogwarts professor and his manipulation
of the goblet of fire which forced harry
to participate in the extremely
dangerous tri-wizard tournament and
ultimately led to harry facing off with
voldemort barty jr was later killed with
a dementor's kiss a sentence for
murdering his father which led to the
extinction of the crouch family line
fully the foleys were a pureblooded
wizarding family whose members were
often sorted into hufflepuff house
hector foley was mentioned as the
minister for magic in the 1920s and
1930s but not much else is known about
this lot
flint the surname of flint was mentioned
here and there throughout the harry
potter series so you may have a vague
recollection of hearing it on occasion
for example sirius black's mother ursula
was a flint before she married phineas
nigellus black
you may also remember the name from a
certain captain of the slithering
quidditch team
marcus flint who harry played opposite
during his younger years at hogwarts
another flint of note includes josefina
flint who was the minister for magic in
the early 1800s
gaunt with a long dark history known
details of the gaunt family can be
traced back as far as the 1600s a witch
intent on preserving the family's
pure-blooded lineage named gormlethorns
was responsible for the murder of
multiple members of her family
throughout the centuries the house of
gaunt was also largely involved in
keeping the chamber of secrets protected
from discovery within the walls of
hogwarts one corvina's gaunt was indeed
given credit for keeping the chamber
concealed in the 1700s when a new
plumbing system was installed in the
castle
the gaunts were so intent on keeping
their bloodline pure that they often
married their own cousins
as descendants of salazar slytherin and
cadmus peverell facts that they were
enormously proud of they also encouraged
inbreeding so as to preserve their
ability to speak parcel tongue the rare
talent of communicating with serpents
the family primarily resided in northern
england just outside of little hangleton
in what became an incredibly run-down
shack
this was of course the home that albus
dumbledore found himself in when hunting
voldemort's horcruxes as mara pigant
daughter of marvolo gaunt was
voldemort's mother
at one point in time the court family
had much gold but as they enjoyed living
quite extravagantly they were eventually
left penniless leaving the last of their
lineage morphin gaunt to live and die in
destitution
green grass the green grass line was a
pure blood wizarding family whose views
grew much more tolerant with subsequent
generations in fact it was a future wife
of draco malfoy a story of green grass
who was known to have openly shirked her
family's anti-muggle views
lestrange without a doubt one of the
best-known lestranges was actually not a
lestrange at all bellatrix lestrange
born bellatrix black married into the
family after wedding rodolfos estrange
it is rumored that she only did so to
uphold the expectation that she would
marry a respectable wizard from another
pureblood family
that said the lestranges were not
unfamiliar with the concept of marrying
their cousins to keep bloodlines pure
similar to the house of gaunt
they were quite wealthy and well known
for their interest in the dark arts so
it's not too surprising that bellatrix
and rodolphus were two of voldemort's
most loyal death eaters other lestranges
of mention include radolphus lestrange
who was minister for magic in the 1800s
and lita lestrange a friend of newton's
commander who was responsible for newt's
expulsion from hogwarts when they too
were pupils there
long bottom neville longbottom is surely
the most well known of this family line
at least by fans of the harry potter
series
he was of course the somewhat
incompetent mate of harry ron and
hermione
eventually however neville overcame his
shortcomings and really came to his own
as he was responsible for killing
voldemort's pet snake and seventh
horcrux nagini among other acts of
bravery
neville was raised by his grandmother
augusta as his parents frank and alice
were tragically tortured to insanity by
death eaters when neville was just a
baby
despite having built impressive careers
as renowned auras before this event the
two never recovered from the dreadful
attack and stayed at st mungo's hospital
for magical maladies and injuries for
the remainder of their lives the long
bottoms never seemed to be overly
concerned about blood purity
however they did not hold the same
reputation for being blood traitors as
say the weasleys
macmillan similar to the long bottoms
the macmillan family seemed to be
neither prejudice nor in favor of muggle
integration
for generations they were a pureblood
family with little to remark on however
ernie macmillan a fellow hufflepuff
student in harry potter's year at
hogwarts made it clear that the family
supported dumbledore during voldemort's
rise to power in the 90s finally
revealing a little of their ideological
views
malfoy the malfoys were a pureblood
family who resided in malfoy manor in
wiltshire england
members of this family who attended
hogwarts were traditionally sorted into
slytherin house and many went on to be
involved in the dark arts
they have a long-standing history of
being in the presence of power
including royal courts of muggle kings
and queens and the ministry of magic
however they were never at the center of
these sources of power
preferring to operate in the shadows
through others it is said that they are
one of the few fanatical pureblood
families that avoided inbreeding as they
were quite aware of the mental
instability that could arise
of course you will recognize malfoy as
the surname as one of the first
antagonists in the series
draco
draco was the only son of lucius and
narcissa malfoy these three were
followers of fort voldemort until they
switched science during the battle of
hogwarts
not not much is known about the knott
family other than that they were pure
bloods who were frequently sorted into
slytherin at hogwarts
catankrasnot has long been suspected to
be the author of the sacred 28
and theodor not was a student at
hogwarts at the same time as harry
theodore's father was a known death
eater who allied himself with voldemort
quite early in his rise to power
ollivander since 382 bc the ollivanders
have been providing the english
wizarding community with quality ones
and they are believed to be one of the
oldest wizarding families in existence
garrick ollivander has been noted as the
earliest member of the family line
within england and it is said that he
came to britain with the romans but it
was not until grant ollivander that the
family went into the wand making
business
of course it was another later garrick
ollivander who made both harry potter
and lord voldemort's ones parkinson
there's not too much to note here the
parkinsons were a pureblood family whose
members included mean-spirited pansy
parkinson a fellow student of harry
potter's who had romantic interests in
draco malfoy and perseus parkinson a
minister for magic in the 1700s
pruitt the pruitt family had pure blood
status but didn't seem to care too much
for the ideologies of blood purity in
fact molly weasley was formerly a pruitt
and we obviously know she did not
support anti-muggle and blood traitor
sentiments her brothers were gideon and
fabian who were both tragically killed
in the first wizarding war by death
eaters it is said that many members of
the pruitt family line had red hair and
large noses rosier a pureblood family
who likely originated in france the
rosiers appeared to place great emphasis
on blood status
this seems to be clear due to one rosier
being affiliated with grindelwald as one
of his acolytes and an evan rossier
being named as one of lord voldemort's
death eaters
raul the rowell family has a varied
history with one damocles raul being a
minister for magic in the 1700s while a
thor finn raul had the reputation as a
known death eater
euphemia raoul is said to have been the
legal guardian of delfini the rumored
biological daughter voldemort and
bellatrix the strange
selwyn a high status pureblood family
the selwyns had at least one death eater
in the family who took part in the
kidnapping of luna lovegood
dolores umbridge the despicable witch
who tortured students in the name of
detention after the ministry appointed
her as a professor at hogwarts claimed
to be from the selwyn family although
this has never been proven
shacklebolt the shackleball family was
by all accounts of pureblooded ancestry
however it is highly unlikely that they
were fanatical about blood purity and
the ideologies behind the sacred 28.
supporting this theory is the existence
of kingsley shakabolt one of the first
auras and a loyal member of the order of
the phoenix
during the second wizarding war kingsley
protected the mughal prime minister and
at one point in the late 1990s he was
temporarily named minister for magic
shafiq there is not much information on
the shafiq family other than that they
were a pureblooded wizarding lineage
that existed until at least the 1930s
when the pureblood directory was
published slughorn known to be quite
wealthy the slughorn clan was tolerant
of muggles and wizarding folk were not
purebloods
formerly the head of slytherin in the
1940s horace locon returned to teacher
dog warts as the potions professor while
harry potter was in his sixth year of
school he had an odd reputation for
seeking out intelligent students
inviting them to dine with him at his
slug club
throughout the years members of the slug
club included lily evans harry potter's
mother and tom riddle who of course went
on to become lord voldemort horace's
father was a high-ranking ministry
official within the department of
international magical cooperation
travers
there is little to say about the
pure-blooded travers family aside from
their inclusion in the sacred 28
a torque will traverse was the head of
the department of magical law
enforcement in the early 1990s
and one of voldemort's death eaters was
called by the name travers and was known
for his hand in the murder of the
mckinnon's
weasley without a doubt even the most
casual of harry potter fans will know
the surname weasley as it is of course
the last name of harry's best mate ron
almost as well known as ron's large
loving family which included his parents
molly and arthur and his six siblings
bill charlie percy fred george and ginny
the weasleys had a long-standing
reputation for their tolerant views of
muggles half-bloods and mudbloods which
frequently gave way to other members of
the sacred 28 referring to this lot as
blood traitors
but just as they were scorned by those
who valued blood purity the weasleys
were outspoken about their resentment
being included in such a list as the
pureblood directory weasleys were
typically sorted into gryffindor house
while attending hogwarts and many
members of the family supported the
order of the phoenix when compared to
other wizarding families you would
likely view them as quite poor
but what they lacked in wealth they more
than made up for in compassion the
weasley family at least when ron was a
boy lived in the borough a large
multi-level home close to archery saint
catch pole in england after voldemort's
final downfall ron went on to marry
hermione granger and have two children
rose and hugo
ginny weasley of course married harry
potter having three children of their
own
james albus and lily yaxley at least one
yaxi was a known death eater
suggesting that this brood had leanings
towards the support of blood purity and
anti-muggle sentiments
not much else is documented about this
particular family
and with that we've made it to the end
of this video did you learn anything new
about families included in the sacred 28
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below
and as always if you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe to
the channel until next time honestly am
i the only person who's ever bothered to
read hogwarts a history
[Music]